hi welcome everybody to our project
which is called the outdoor water
conservation case studies for the
Rockland County Legislature so as you
can see this is our agenda for today and
I'm going to be taking you through the
background for what we worked on this
semester and then two of our other
members in the group Nicki and Aaron are
going to look at some of the specifics
of what we worked on so you had you
heard a little bit already about the
purpose of the workshop but we wanted to
give our own explanation so the workshop
gives students the opportunity to work
on get real world experience on apply'
projects working with a client and it
allows them to develop certain useful
skills such as communication skills
working with professionals as well as
problem solving with individual as an
individual or within the context of a
group and this will help us overcome
some of the problems we will face after
graduation so this is the team that we
worked with and as you can see we bought
a wide range of knowledge experience and
interests to the two this semester and
of course all of us have the similarity
of a sustainable development major or
concentration the clients that we worked
with this semester was Alden wolf who is
the chairman of the Environmental
Committee for the Rockland County
Legislature we also consulted with Dan
Miller who is the Bureau head of water
supply for the Rockland County
Department of Health as well as Stuart
Bremen who is a researcher at
lamont-doherty Earth Observatory so for
those of you who aren't familiar
rockland county is in southeastern New
York State and it is currently facing
water scarcity due to population growth
pressure and land-use changes so one
important thing to know about Rockland
County is that the majority of its water
supply comes from a private water
supplier called United Water and this
has led to some complications and
difficulties in implementing policies on
water use so the Rockland County
Legislature is looking into a way to
solve this problem by addressing the
demand problem with water use and this
is what brought them to the sustainable
development workshop and so now I'm
going to turn you over first to Nikki
who is going to discuss one of the
possible solutions we looked at for
examine in the sensitivity analysis
which analyzed different water saving
programs that Lachlan could potentially
use and then later Aaron is going to
look in depth at one of the case studies
which is another option that we
developed on outdoor non-emergency water
conservation ordinances Thank You
Caitlin okay so we worked on the
sensitivity analysis which was something
of a sub-project for the workshops main
goal this year so this is really an
extension of last year's workshop the
spring 2012 group analyzed the
cost-effectiveness of seven different
water conservation programs that could
potentially address water scarcity in
rockland county to do this they used an
excel-based software program which was
provided by the Alliance for water
efficiency and we also use the same
software in our sensitivity analysis so
the significance of the sensitivity
analysis is because last semesters
project relied on a number of
assumptions as inputs for their model
for example they had to guess how many
people would participate in each program
they were reasonably estimated guesses
but they were still guesses so the
sensitivity analysis looks at how much
variation will occur in our outputs if
we make changes in our assumptions to do
this we performed research and used case
studies to project a reasonable range of
variations and our inputs and we
recorded the effect on our results it's
also important because it tests the
stability of last semesters work and it
supports decision making and
recommendations that may stem from the
work that we've
in the workshop for our methodology we
based our analysis on two models there
is a conservative model and an
optimistic model these models both took
into account several variables that
might success that might affect the
success of our outputs as well as the
variables that we personally changed
which were the participation rate and
the unit water savings for each program
we then recorded the gross water savings
and the utility and customer benefit
cost ratios we did this for each
individual program and then we combined
all of our programs into an ultimate
optimistic and an ultimate conservative
to get an idea of what the total range
could be if we implemented these
programs so I'm just going to take you
through an example of one of the
programs that we looked at which was the
water waste ordinance so we examined a
generic outdoor water conservation
ordinance which didn't have anything to
do with rebates or special water-saving
technology it was simply an ordinance
that would say for example you cannot
water your lawn on X days last semesters
report didn't really have very much
research based on the water savings or
participation rates so we really focused
on that one way we did this was we used
the United Water survey to get an idea
of how many people how many people water
their lawns in Rockland County on a
regular basis we also took into account
a couple other important assumptions one
of which was the potential annual unit
water savings which we calculated to be
81 gallons per household per day and we
got this from a combination of the of
information on the lamont-doherty
website as well as further hypothesizing
on our part we also included 25% of
potential for optimistic and 10 for
conservative and this is this takes into
account how often regular lawn watering
occurs as well as how many days the
ordinance would be implemented so for
our results we found that the ordinance
program was cost effect can be
considered cost effective in all of our
scenarios in both the conservative and
opt-in
istic as well as the semesters work and
less semesters work we also saw
meaningful water savings achieved in
both scenarios which amounted to about
360,000 gallons per day in the
optimistic and 80,000 in the
conservative these are definitely
meaningful because our standard is the
projected long-term supply requirement
of 7.5 million gallons per day so there
are a couple there are a few programs
that were consistently cost effective
both last year in this last semester in
this semester there was a residential
high-efficiency toilet rebate program
there was the wastewater the water waste
ordinance and the single-family high
efficiency washer rebate program that
would require a slight modification for
mission eligibility but it was cost
effective with that modification and we
do recommend that we also found that in
our cumulative q middle of model where
we put all the individual programs
together that there was a total water
savings in 2021 of over 3 million
gallons in the optimistic model and over
1 million gallons in the conservative
model and again this is measured against
that 7.5 million gallon per day standard
so it is meaningful so this chart just
shows all the projected water saving
scenarios over all of our different
models the ones that we calculate that
we really want to draw attention to our
the Green Line which is the second from
the top and are our new optimistic model
and the red line which is all the way at
the bottom which is our conservative
model we do want to point out that the
that the old optimistic model the orange
line on the very top is very clearly out
of the range that we calculated that's
because we found that there was far too
optimistic assumptions in one of the
programs last semester which was the
toilet rebate program that combined with
the washer program comprised two-thirds
of our total water savings so that shows
up as like quite a significant effect on
our graph which is why that is outside
of the range so just some final
conclusions last semesters limits were
found to be valid based upon our
sensitivity analysis with the exception
of that
efficiency toilet rebate program which
we discussed before was too optimistic
last semester we also found that about
two-thirds of our water savings came
from rebates targeted at high efficiency
appliances which would be high
efficiency washing machines and high
efficiency toilets we also want to point
out that the water waste ordinance while
it was a small effect it was definitely
meaningful and we do want to point out
that that particular program is only in
effect for a portion of the year people
don't tend to water their lawns in
winter at least in New York so our
numbers are annual but we hypothesized
that if we looked at the peak usage
season this water waste ordinance would
actually comprise a much more
significant portion of our total effect
so with that I'm going to hand it off to
Aaron and he's going to talk about the
more qualitative portion of our project
which entailed further researching water
waste ordinance case studies okay I'm
going to talk about one of the case
studies and the problem that we approach
this with what trying to solve is how to
introduce non-emergency outdoor water
conservation ordinances in rockland
county our methodology was to get a wide
scope of across the u.s. of water
ordinances which are already in place in
certain counties towns and cities we
looked from the east coast all the way
to the west coast Alex looked
specifically at California in Washington
State Melissa and Caitlin in the greater
new york city area specifically in
Nassau County and Shelley and I looked
at North Carolina Massachusetts at New
Jersey today i'll be here is a list of
the 11 locations that we looked at but
today i'll be specifically talking about
carry which is in inland north carolina
a little background on Carrie Carrie is
very similar to rockland in terms of
demographic it's an affluent suburb it's
very close to UNC Chapel Hill and NC
State rally it's a suburb of rally and
the population has
by 50,000 over the past decade coupled
with a persistent drought from 1999
until 2002 and the driest year on record
the water scarcity has been exasperated
they only have one major source which is
a surface source and that's ever it be
Jordan Lake with a maximum withdrawal
under law as of 24 million gallons per
day residential customers account for 71
percent of total consumption and
forty-two percent of total demand is
associated with residential irrigation
making it a very good place to start for
water conservation and unlike Rocklin
water and carry is managed at the town
level and they are able to pass
ordinances and directly influence the
water supply that way in 1996 they had
great oversight and they implemented a
conservation and demand management
program with a stated goal to reduce
reduce a per capita consumption by
twenty percent by the year 2015 which is
on track to be met one of the water
ordinances passed in 1998 and these are
all indicative of what we found in most
of the locations that we looked at the
first one was the wastewater ordinance
which outlaws the the wasteful use of
water on impervious surfaces such as
blacktop and concrete say if you're
washing your car and you leave your hose
running for an expended extended period
of time you may attract the attention of
an officer and also the negligent
treatment of major leaks if your hose or
irrigation system has a major leak and
it's wasting water then you also may be
subject to a warning and then a fine the
rain sensor ordinance is very much what
it sounds like it's a mechanism which
senses when it rains and shuts off the
irrigation system all customers
residential and non-residential are
required to install them and it costs
about twenty to thirty dollars making it
affordable for the local demographic and
the final one is an alternate day
watering ordinance which allows
customers to water their lawns on an
alternate basis so odd addresses on one
day even on the next on a rotating basis
although there are a few exceptions if
you have a drip irrigation
or any high efficiency technology to
deliver water straight to the root then
you're allowed to water any day of the
week and this also goes for private
wells and ponds on properties as far as
implementation carried a lot 185
thousand dollars for five what they call
public education officers to patrol and
look for violations and they typically
patrol during Monday through Friday
normal business hours but during drought
periods they will patrol 24-7 and as you
can see from this graph during drought
periods when they implemented 24-7
patrolling there is a huge spike in
ordinances so this would tell us that
maybe the amount of ordinances reported
sort of goes along with how much they
are actually patrolling but aside from
sort of punitive measures carrie has a
huge emphasis on education and in the
symphony with these ordinances they have
also adopted education programs at the
elementary level they have town
employees go in and speak to second and
third graders and give them towards of
water treatment facilities and they have
community outreach programs that teach
residents about conservation methods as
well results in Cary they have been
successful in they are on track to
reduce reduce per capita consumption by
twenty percent by the year 2015 although
their population continues to increase
at an annual rate of five percent so
this means overall consumption continues
to rise and currently they are at fifty
percent of total supply as far as demand
right now and the EPA estimates by 2030
78% an increase to seventy eight percent
in demand to sort of fix this problem
one of the methods they are using is to
start to use reclaimed water which
removes the solid waste from water and
which then can be used for irrigation or
manufacturing processes just not for
drinking
so overall lessons that we've sort of
observed for rockland county there are
many we put them in two broad categories
of relationships enforcement incentives
and education programs and water
efficient landscaping as far as
enforcement and education compliance is
key in these if the community is not
involved if they're not ordered
conservation-minded then the ordinances
will not be successful although the
Rockland County Legislature has limited
ability to really implement education
programs we suggest that they look into
all avenues possible to get the
community on board the leveraging
relationships between the layers of
government is especially important in
rockland because water scarcity is a
very localized phenomenon because
otherwise the surrounding municipalities
they have plentiful water it just so
happens that Rockland County was not
allotted any water from New York City
supply when it was established in the
early 1900s also learning from the past
and writing flexible ordinances that
allow exemptions such as drip irrigation
or if the customer waters their lawn by
hand then it's also important to include
that in the ordinance and lastly water
efficient landscaping using high
efficiency varieties of grass and
methods to apply the water it's more of
a holistic approach and we also think
that on top of the ordinances that it
should be explored in conclusion we sort
of have introduced a wide variety of
options for rockland county to look into
but even with the complexities of
introducing water ordinances there is a
clear benefit as far as conservation
goes in water demand reduction if they
are to implement them if you have any
questions feel free to ask any of us
across the United States
compare/contrast your case studies well
Stuart Bremen who steward Gavin
recognized the beginning he's kind of
been our special advisor he started out
by giving us a few recommendations and
contacts to search for and kind of
follow up with that he's met on his
conservation sort of experiences and
then specifically for the west coast it
involved a lot of kind of hit and miss I
would talk to someone and then they
would refer me to someone else there's a
lot of internal referrals seems the
conservation community is pretty tight
knit across the u.s. so we worked by
that method and just overall
geographically we're try to find
ordinances around Rockland County there
are close to where we're looking at so
what was the big surprise for this
coming at this video me you guys were
building on data from previous semester
so I'm just wondering if there was
something that happened that you were
shocked to see or was it really just
what you expected basically what we
noticed because there was seven
different water conservation program
water students programs from last
semester and then it was narrowed down
to five that were found be
cost-effective last semester and then
this semester we found that the major
one that was the most cost-effective and
duct tape saved a lot of water and also
had a very high on benefit cost ratio
was the high efficiency toilets for the
earth Nigel homes so in addition to
saving a lot of months leaving a lot of
water also it's a very cost effective
program
and on the case study said well we
didn't really the reason why I be looked
into this to begin with was be his last
semester so last semester is focus on
analyzing these different programs they
took up to analyze the range the
sensitivity analysis in the case study
one of the programs that was the least
well researched was the one that the
case studies are took up I I don't know
if you guys want to speak to any
surprises that you found in the new case
studies well I think one of the major
surprises was how they enforce these
nuttin ordinances not necessarily
through just punitive measures because I
was also looking at Chapel Hill which is
reduce per capita consumption by thirty
percent they do not even have officers
who patrol it's strictly through
education positive I found as well
same in New York even when there wasn't
ordinance in place didn't mean that
anyone knew about it we we talk to
people even within the water department
and some people said what our next
option because it was driving the 80s
and it hasn't been revised since so I
was specifically surprised about that
part of it yeah late a lot of them seem
to be the most aware about the
ordinances they had during water
emergency so for drought conditions and
that seems to be the greatest focused in
the most immediate area around Rockland
so either they weren't really they
didn't have any non revis ordinances or
it just wasn't really a focus or have
even been sort of just like forgotten
about in the meantime
I'm just going along with what Aaron
said before I dive in to research in my
ordinances I felt that probably the more
you spend on like enforcement maybe the
better results you will get but what I
found out through my research a long
time when you actually don't even have a
budget for enforcement you actually see
a lot
actually for example neighbors touching
each other and looking for violators
when you have even other restrictions so
there's actually a lot of waste very
cost effective ways to enforce
thank you guys for coming I like that
question because we want things that
they haven't necessarily prepared for
like what surprised you about the
project so we're actually this was
really thanks everyone for being on time
and keeping to the time limits so we're
gonna break now I just want to thank
remember to thank key people I want to
thank the students first of all for all
their hard work it's in and actually the
the high point of this is always fun but
the high point of semester in my
experience is when we go to the offices
of the clients and actually deliver this
a little more technical actually
significantly more technical
presentation again to the experts and I
have always really been amazed at how
skilled you guys have gotten a lot of it
comes out with more difficult questions
technical questions which really are fun
I think you'll you you'll enjoy that and
find it very satisfying as well but I
also want to thank Eileen for doing
continued excellent ta assistance
semester dr. Brightman again for he's
been painstaking in attending so many
classes as a liaison to fit to sort of
again as they say an unusual
relationship with our workshop which has
worked out very well because I I don't I
could never bring in this kind of
technical knowledge because it's not my
area of work and then last but not least
i want to thank Natalie and Jessica for
the admin assistants they give us that
they just they never say no to anything
we ask and we they've provided so much
help from Metro cards too if we need to
get some lunches or food we don't have
food here this this time right oh we do
excuse me so anyway this couldn't be
done without the continued assistance
from Natalie and Jessica in the whole
administration